here's gay pete again he went on he was
on the viewing same video from before
same segment and and just listen to the
lies listen to the lies i mean it they
train them i don't know where these
people get media training you see how
klobuchar what she just did there was
she was asked a very direct question she
deflected the question answered
something else completely watch pete
when the lunatics at the view ask pete
about bill
hb1557 which is what they call the don't
say gay bill but of course as you know
could just as easily be called the don't
say straight bill your husband chaston
is a teacher
and he's been a vocal critic of what's
going on in my state of florida when the
with the so-called don't say gay
law now
which
he says will kill kids do you agree
and you know as a politician because
this this
strikes you as you know your husband is
a teacher
you are uh
obviously lgbtq yourself and you are now
a parent yeah
so how do you feel yeah he's right and
and i think every law to be judged for
the effect it's going to have on real
people in real life and i i get the
political reasons why they're doing this
by the way some of those political
reasons they don't have a plan on
anything else right i mean they they
don't have a plan on dealing with
inflation or or dealing with with gas
prices or dealing with the issues we
can't get home insurance in florida
we're banning all sorts of conversations
easier right it's easier politically but
this is going to hurt people
nothing he is nothing he's not a man
he's not a man he's he's a pretend man
in a well-fitted suit that's all he is
so let's just go through each one first
off uh what's her name anna navarro what
what a horrible human being she is uh
she says chaston's a teacher the
implication that just because he's a
teacher he should have some authority to
discuss sex and gender identity with
your kids so what he's a teacher so what
i don't know what he what's he a teacher
of can we find out what he's a teacher
of i don't care if he's a history
teacher he should be teaching history if
he's a math teacher he should be
teaching math if he's a science teacher
including a biology teacher he should be
teaching biology and if he's a grade
school teacher there are basic uh
learning blocks of education that he
should be learning or have the kids
building blocks that would be fine in an
elementary school as well but he has no
right to talk about gender identity or
sexuality with a second grader okay so
that's that's number one uh
that chaston says that this is going to
kill kids that bill hb1557 is going to
kill kids and pete agrees yeah that's
right peter agrees it's going to kill
kids so if kids if second graders seven
year olds can't discuss gender identity
with the state employee and have that
state employee hide it from the parents
that's going to kill them complete lie
complete lie but again all they can do
is lie about everything apparently he's
a humanities teacher and a theater
teacher oh is it and a diversity teacher
now i think you're punking me he's a
humanities teacher a theater teacher and
a diversity club teacher
then navarro says that uh she says to
pete you're lgbtq yourself so that
implies
that pete is a lesbian okay so pete is a
lesbian check pete is gay lg gay okay
he's gay got it he's bi he's bisexual so
he's banging chicks on the side i wonder
if chad chaston knows that uh he's trans
pete is trans also that is something
else and you know with these well-fitted
suits like get this gal address you know
what i'm talking about and q which i
honestly don't know what it is
apparently he's a conspiracy theorist
he's some mega far-right q
anonymous
he's just awful oh and then oh and then
then the best part of this
why are they pushing these bills
pete says they're pushing them because
they have no plans on inflation and gas
prices
actually
dave dunker actually gay pete
it's your administration it's your boss
that is printing money out of control
that is causing inflation it's your
idiotic policies related to keystone
pipeline your administration
related to keystone related to
everything you've done that have
destroyed the economy okay it's you guys
that have done all this what does that
have to do with the governor what is
florida what is florida's governor have
to do with inflation throughout the
country what does florida's governor
have to do with gas prices throughout
the country actually gas prices are way
better in florida than they are in
california okay you you're just you lie
about everything oh and then that wizard
uh navarro says that you can't get home
insurance in florida i have literally no
idea what she's talking about i just got
here i just got to florida i had to get
home insurance you're not going to
believe what i did guys this was
incredible you'll be homeowners one day
i picked up the phone and i called an
insurance company and i got a couple of
quotes and then i picked the best rate
it's [ __ ] extraordinary anna navarro
i have to we have to get this clip to
navarro she's living with no home
insurance okay the woman i'm actually
told i live somewhat close to her
wouldn't that be horrible if i saw her
on the street that would be